but as our borders are inspects fish in
the Philippines we have a very real
crisis here animal shelters overflowing
with dogs that illegal aliens have
ditched at the border and it really is
a tragedy Lori Simons runs the Big Dog
Ranch Rescue she joins us tonight Lori
thank you so much for calling our
attention to this uh and and for doing
something about it so describe quickly
if you would the nature of the problem
thank you Tuckers
thank you Tucker for helping me bring
this to light it's a huge problem
um when we got down to Eagle Pass down
at the Rio Grande last week and saw
hundreds and hundreds of starving and
Abandoned Dogs left to fend for
themselves from illegal immigrants that
cross the border with their dogs then
they get on buses and just leave them
Behind These dogs can't survive on their
own and the National Guard and a friend
of mine from Blue Line moving who had
gone down there to do a border cleanup
had reached out to us and we were really
shocked at just how big the problem was
and how much these animals were
suffering
and this couldn't come at a worse time
Tucker shelters throughout the country
are overflowing everywhere owner
surrenders are up 60 throughout the
country because people are having to
make the hard choice of whether to feed
their families and fill up their car
with gas and Heat their homes or give up
their dog they just can't afford to care
for them
well I don't I mean first of all I would
say anyone who'd abandoned a dog at the
border should not be allowed in this
country should be deported immediately
we don't want people like that living
here at all second how can our amen it's
really a sign of low character in my
opinion so how can our viewers help that
you are running an effort to save these
dogs who did nothing wrong or abandon
um can how can people help
well Big Dog Ranch Rescue is the largest
no-kill dog rescue in the country with
our Palm Beach County location we have
750 dogs there right now we're over
overflowing trying to rescue so many and
just opened an Alabama location you can
please come adopt one of these dogs
there's so many that need some or donate
it's donations keep us going go to our
website at
bdrr.org and help us save more lives
appreciate you doing this and for also
telling us about it Lori Simons thank
you so much
thank you so much Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight